[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Max how
can we help hi uh so I recently invested
20 months ago in a piece of real estate
I got it for 385,000 it's probably worth
it's Le at least half a m today but
probably like half a m to
550 and the problem is I'm 25 years old
and and I've been kind of renting out
rooms while living here to friends and
everything's going great but my
co-signer was not a parent or a
girlfriend is actually a person that
I've worked with at a restaurant and she
recently told me that she would like her
name to get off of the loan so that she
could start uh looking for a piece of
real estate for herself and my loan is
not
assumable and the only way for me to get
her name off is to refinance which would
double my interest rate right now oh
where's my Tums where's the B Max Max
Max dude this is like a dumbb and Dumber
sequel how did you guys get into this
mess so you can't afford the house and
this friend is like hey bro I'll sign
for you yeah why I'm good for the money
did you not think about what would
happen later on down the line and
whether or not they're going to want a
piece of this and how they're going to
get their name off so I thought about it
and within because I'm um a contractor
type so I thought okay um within two
years I'll be able to refinance and
because I only put about 5% down as you
do when you're broke and can't afford a
house yes and my goal was to work up at
least 20% equity which I'm pretty
positive I have now okay so I I I went
in with the mindset of okay you know
I'll I'll fix this up I'll get the yeah
and that interest rates would stay the
same forever and now uh
oh yeah okay so your only option here is
to refinance to get their name off the
loan and you're saying if I refinance
it's going to double my
payment uh I mean yeah it'll it'll just
definitely um make it higher and I've
you know I've kind of broken even in
terms of renting the rooms out no you're
just broke I mean the the whole this
money scheme of getting roommates is not
panning out you're about to lose this
house you can't afford it yeah Max have
you run the numbers like when you say go
up a little bit it's doubling have you
what is that going do let's say the
payment doubles your roommates keep
paying you the same you're now
underwater aren't
you if I don't think I I mean I have one
more room that I can rent and I I was
just about to make passes and what
happens when they don't pay or when it's
vacant
then it's a it's a bad bad move I know
so we've got to look at some other
Solutions here one of them might be we
have to sell this place that was once a
dream has now become the nightmare we
stepped into it too soon too early with
a friend who cosigned who now wants out
of it and uh you know I don't know
what's what's the are they still friends
with you I imagine this is friendship is
not going to last very long it's you
know surpris there's no real hard
feelings with it um she was just you
know under the impression that at that
2-year mark that I would be you know
we'd be ready to refinance and get her
off which I and how many years has it
been it's been um not even two years
it's been 20 months okay and so what is
the payment now and what would it be if
you
refinance so I think the payment now is
close to
2,800 and the refinance payment I think
is
um he I checked about two weeks ago but
it was I imagine between 34 and
3600 and that's with current interest
rates I think so yeah and that's on a
30-y
year okay and what are you making right
now with the roommates
renting So currently 2600 and I have
another room open that I could easily
get 7 to 800 for okay and you have
essentially You' you've not been paying
much rent at all or no okay the major I
mean when I first got it it was um a
cosmetic you know fixer upper so a lot
of the rooms needed paint and what was
your long-term play on this my long-term
play was to to buy this house to um kind
of just rent out until I could afford it
on my own and then maybe kind of do the
the Burr method and I rented this out
with you know either a full family or
the people that are still here I'd be
able to do the same thing on another
piece of uh okay first of all you
realize you're in the hosle business now
that's essentially what you're do you're
running a hostel and you're about to be
you're living in it with all these
people I got another room come on and
it's just this is wackadoodle I think
for you for this what's your what's your
income every month um every month I make
about four grand okay so number one
you're going to have to float the
difference
as we deal with whatever the next few
months look like so you're going to have
to start paying uh a bunch of rent I'd
sell the house George you told him to
sell the house I I think you need to get
out of this thing I truly don't think
you're going to anyone who's if you've
kind of like you've been watching the
Tik tocks about the bur method and
everyone in real estate business like
dude this is the way you become a real
estate Guru trust me well this is the
reality of it yeah but what it run the
scenario for him real quick George C
Vision if he sells it right now with
this Equity what would you get out of
this if you sold it you you gave your
you know do they get a share with the
appreciation so they actually they only
did this and it it seems crazy this was
someone that was my boss for a really
long time and she wanted 0% you know in
it unless I defaulted and then then then
we would have to kind of
rediscussed it to help me out of the
goodness of their heart okay so how much
money would you make if you sell it
today for the
550 um on the loan I think I owe about
[Music]
365 so I would make it close to 200 and
then you'd be out of this mess and you
have actually gotten out of this with
the closing costs and and everything I'd
probably you know that would take
another 20,000 off or so I'd imagine you
walk away with 175 and you're out of
this mess and you're not having to worry
about having six roommates just to fill
the thing and hope one of them doesn't
vacate and hope you don't have to evict
one and hope you don't have to pay the
rent to make up the difference but right
now the refinancing at the current rates
and paying four grand a month and trying
to deal with this it feels like too much
of a nightmare for as young as you are
and as much successes you could have in
the
future okay could you get a cheaper
place if you sold it and put 175 down
the thing is in this uh neighborhood I'm
in you know within an hour of um man
there's you know it's very competitive
and it's it's really difficult it's New
York City it's always going to be
competitive Max why did you call us did
you want us to validate what you're
doing or did you are you even open to
what we just told you well I I have the
thing I've been um listening into the
show trying to find a similar situation
and I couldn't really I guess find one
and I I figured you guys would tell me
to just sell it but yeah cuz you're
about to have a four grand mortgage
payment and you make four grand a
month yeah that's the scary part and
you're a landlord you know running a
hostel you're going to be stressed out
of your mind you've got to get out of
jail card here and we're telling you to
take it but I don't know if you care
more about your your your your mental
emotional and Financial Health or
disappointing people on Tik Tok that you
don't even know because they told you to
do it it feels like there's this like
you think we're giving you this
unconventional wisdom you got reality as
my friend Dr John deloney would say and
the reality is this was a risky gamow
that did not pay off and it's time to
get out while we still have our butt